you will no doubt recall that Donald
Trump made a huge deal out of Hillary
Clinton's supposed careless handling of
classified sensitive and secret
information back when he was running
against her in 2016 and we then learned
that lots of people have been working in
the Trump White House without permanent
security clearances some because they
simply were unable to get the clearances
on the basis of their background others
may be indifference or laziness who
really knows and we are now learning
that Donald Trump's own lawyers who are
representing him in the Trump Russia
investigation by robert muller also
apparently don't have the required
clearances to actually discuss a lot of
the sensitive issues that would
conceivably come up if donald trump is
interviewed by robert muller John Dowd
who left Trump's legal team he did have
the proper security clearance
but he's gone Jay Sekulow the guy who
created the list of nearly 50 questions
that we talked about earlier this week
does not have the required clearances he
wouldn't even be able to sit in the room
with Trump during that interview and
apparently this is an issue for many
people on Donald Trump's legal team
according to a number of sources
familiar with what's going on and the
one guy on Trump's legal team personal
legal team who does have the appropriate
clearance is Ty Cobb but we learned a
few days ago that Ty Cobb is leaving by
the end of the month so this is
ridiculous and I know that in the era of
hyper normalization where it's scandal
after scandal this is probably not going
to rank super high but we are very
quickly heading towards a showdown on
the limits of Robert Moeller subpoena
power over a sitting president and the
lawyers who are presumably going to be
involved in sorting out well does Trump
have to appear or does he not have to
appear if he's subpoenaed they are not
even cleared at a high enough level in
terms of security clearance to discuss
the topics that would be brought up
during the meeting between robert muller
and donald trump and the reason that
this really matters other than the sort
of sheer incompetence and indifference
to security protocol by the Trump
administration is that if there is going
to be an interview the subject matter of
the interview would require these
lawyers to have the clearances that I'm
talking about the clearances that they
lack they are going to end up having to
like sit outside of the room and of
course Donald Trump would be allowed to
consult with them
but it is yet another way in which it is
going to get in the way of us just
figuring out what is Trump know and when
does he know it and I know that I don't
want to ascribe 4d chess playing to
people who don't even seem to know the
rules of 3d chess so to speak but could
this be another way just to interfere
with the flow of that eventual meeting
which is hey listen if we don't have the
security clearances Trump is entitled to
representation no matter what we sit
outside and every question Trump is
asked he says excuse me and steps
outside would that count against the two
to three hour limit that might be placed
on this I don't know the answer but I
hesitate to say it's a genius move
because they seem so incompetent I
wonder if they'll claim that this is all
protected by attorney-client privilege
right which doesn't seem like it would
apply now but remember Don Jr was
supposed to testify before either the
Senate or House committee yes of some
sort and he claimed that a phone call
between him and his father was protected
by attorney-client privilege because
their lawyers were listening in on the
conversation yeah certainly didn't apply
then wouldn't apply now but they would
make the case
listen lawyers were in Washington at the
time of that there Washington DC was
filled with lawyers at the time that
that took place so therefore they don't
have to talk about that it's actually
fascinating assuming that this isn't
some kind of 40 chess move it's actually
fascinating to watch the ways in which
everybody surrounding Trump just lacks
competence and how everything that was
put on Hillary Clinton by Donald Trump
appears to have been projection right
and here we're talking about she
mishandled sensitive information in
Trump's 15 months in office 16 months
now I guess Trump has spilled secrets
from an ally to a Russian spy recruiter
in the Oval Office he has dozens of
people working for him without permanent
security clearances he announced
military plans on Twitter which he said
no president should ever do because it
tells your enemies what it is that
you're gonna be doing and he's been
caught lying endless times and now his
own lawyers don't seem to have the
appropriate security clearances but it
was Hillary who mishandled sensitive
information I know it's way too early to
talk about 2020
but could a Democratic challenger use
this against him this double standard
never would it to scrape off him because
he's new and on the the double standards
and lies are so ubiquitous that they
seem to not be affecting him in any way
and by the way I'm glad you mentioned
Teflon Don I think that Teflon Don
refers to what's the mobster Don Oh is
there someone else with that
yeah I'm now forgetting the mobster that
that was convicted Don okay I how I
don't know anyway apparently Teflon Don
originally referred to I'm gonna feel so
stupid when someone writes in I just
thought of this based on a book I
recently read Don Wow I just feel like
an idiot I mean the idea that nothing
sticks nothing right never yeah it's
kind of and the charges would fall off
of this mobster until he was eventually
convicted and I'm gonna feel really dumb
because I just cannot remember the guy's
last name anyway no the Trump is don't
care we shouldn't be waiting around
expecting his supporters to say wait a
second this guy's a liar we can't
support them it's just not gonna happen
today's program is made possible in part
by fruit or fruit or is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board from politics to
sports and everything in between you
wager on predictions about real world
events using for tours in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
and improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account
and follow me by clicking the link in
the description if you're watching this
on YouTube
this week on futur I pose the question
will there be a congressional hearing
regarding the Trump sexual assault
allegations what do you think click the
link in the description and place your
bets and you can browse the politics
category on futur to wager on other
predictions sign up now at root or calm
and start making your forecasts on
political topics and tons of other
topics totally free available on both
Android and iOS
as well as on web browsers that is fut
uur dot-com